valérie qui a travaillé plusieurs années
dans une firme conseil dans le domaine
de la santé
enseigne maintenant cinquième année
quand je l'appelle la conscience
colajanni lui comme une bénédiction
c'était le coup de pouce qui me manquait
pour faire le changement carrière que je
voulais faire diplômée en psychologie en
criminologie on l'embauché même s'il n'a
pas le bac et le brevet d'enseignement
requis par le ministère de l'éducation
je ne connais pas nécessairement à tous
on apprend comme usine sur le terrain
faute voyant les mêmes si on côtoyait
les collègues il ya beaucoup d'aspects
la technique le dans l'école
c'était ce kit ainsi que 10 ha et
valérie n'est pas seul avec la pandémie
le manque d'enseignants est encore plus
criant dans les écoles depuis cinq ans
le nombre d'enseignants non légalement
qualifiés qui ont un permis de
tolérances d'engagement n'a cessé
d'augmenter de 896 il ya cinq ans ils
sont passés à 2210 une augmentation de
146% n'étant pénurie d'enseignants
actuellement dont on a besoin d'avoir
des gens faut s'occuper nos enfants dans
cette école secondaire de laval environ
10% de l'équipe n'a pas les compétences
requises pour enseigner mais le
directeur affirme qu'il n'a pas le choix
il a besoin d'enseignants on sélectionne
les personnes pour lesquelles il ya le
plus grand potentiel d'intégration à à
moyen et à long terme des gens qui ont
des compétences qui peuvent se
transférer dans l'enseignement donc je
pense que c'est important de défaire ce
mec-là qui est ce son nom légalement
quel fils tout des incompétents de la
moitié des enseignants non légalement
qualifiés du québec se retrouve dans la
grande région de montréal
les besoins sont tellement grands ici
que les universités n'arrive peut
suffire à la demande
voilà c'est ce que ça reste préoccupant
pour la qualité de l'enseignement qui
dispensait ceni les universités offrent
des formations adaptées pour ces
enseignants
alors que les centres de services
scolaires les soutiennent au quotidien
j selon moi les compétences pour en
finir mais va lire est tout de même
décidé de suivre une formation
universitaire à distance pour devenir
éventuellement une véritable enseignante
ici jean philippe robillard à radio
canada montréal